joining us now is the foreign secretary
liz trusmus trust thanks for joining us
on the program this morning we're
heading towards a recession aren't we
we are in a very very difficult economic
situation we're facing some very very
serious global headwinds and you know as
you've said inflation is extremely high
what we're doing is working to
increase growth in our economy attract
investment to the united kingdom to
face down these global headwinds but
there's no doubt it is very difficult
for people across britain and in fact
across the world
what exactly tell me what exactly is the
downside to a windfall tax why don't we
do that at least in the short term
well i've just talked about how we need
to attract investment one of the
successes we've had is the
very high number of people in work we've
got the lowest unemployment since 1974
and the reason we've been able to do
that is because britain has been
attracting investment attracting new
businesses to come up and set up in the
united kingdom and the problem with the
windfall tax is it makes it difficult to
attract future investment into our
country so there is a cost in imposing a
tax like that and my view
is lower taxes are the best way to
attract more investment to get the
businesses into this country that can
create these high paid jobs which is
what we need to face down these global
headwinds and i i travel in a lot a lot
in my job as foreign secretary
i've seen very very high inflation
elsewhere too and the reason is we're
coming out of the covid crisis there
really is a problem with supply chains
we've got the appalling uh war that
russia has started uh in ukraine uh
which is affecting food prices it's
affecting oil and gas prices and we're
seeing those global headwinds in the
united kingdom what we need to do is
make sure we're attracting the
investment we're attracting the
businesses to be able to create those
future jobs they're going to help us
deal with this very difficult situation
yeah but that argument immediately
starts to unravel when you hear from the
head of bp the ceo bernard looney who
they made 6.2 billion 6.2 billion
dollars profit in the first quarter of
this year and they say don't care
whether you give us a windfall tax or
not it's not going to impact on the
investment that we are going to make in
the uk so as far as these oil giants are
concerned a one-off windfall tax will
help the people of wigan here bringing
down the cost uh that they are having to
shell out every single month and it
could be the difference between them
eating and heating he says it's okay to
do it so why don't the government just
do it well what i want to see is
businesses like that investing in new
infrastructure in the united kingdom we
need those high quality jobs we need
success in the future so what those
businesses who have made profits during
the last few years need to be doing is
unlocking their balance sheets and
investing in the united kingdom that's
the way we're going to get the
sustainable future that we all want
but he says that he is going to do that
anyway
well then he can do even more if he's
got more uh profits that have been
raised during during this period
so you're suggesting that bp should
invest even more money in the uk than
they are already
i i absolutely am and we know
we've got a massive issue with energy
you know we need more green energy we
need more nuclear energy in the united
kingdom what i want to see energy
companies doing is investing in those
facilities so the next time we have an
oil and gas price spike which is one of
the major causes of this issue
we're seeing that investment in new
energy so it's easier for us to
withstand it and keep prices low for
consumers
okay so you're content you'd rather have
a a recession a short-term recession
hopefully then get these big oil giants
to pay when full taxes is that what
you're saying in bleak terms
nobody can predict whether or not there
will be a
you know economic problems the best
thing the government can do is attract
the investment keep people
in work we're doing what we can to help
households i know the chancellor is
looking at further measures that we can
take of course we completely understand
it's a very difficult situation for
people across the country including in
wigan we are facing these global
headwinds and we need to deal with them
by attracting the investment into the
united kingdom making sure that we have
those high quality jobs of course we're
very very concerned about the
circumstances people are facing that's
why we've created things like the
household support fund to help people
get through these difficult times but
ultimately our country's long-term
future is dependent on creating those
high-paid jobs getting that investment
into britain
so how many hours a week should people
have to work in order not to be poor
it's up to people how many uh hours they
work
how many hours they work a week i mean
this is what we are doing is making sure
that all households are supported
through our household support fund it's
not about how many hours people are
working it's about making sure there are
enough of those high paid jobs in the
future
and we're creating at present
lowest unemployment as i've said since
1974 so that we can weather this very
very difficult storm
your home office ministers tell me just
on monday that people should work more
hours than they won't be poor
i think that's a mischaracterization of
what she said okay
we know that it's very very difficult
times for people across the united
kingdom we know that
we are facing higher costs this is a
global phenomenon there's high inflation
across the world because of the energy
price spike
because of the issues with russia
ukraine because of the fact we're
recovering from covered and we want to
do all we can to support households
through this difficult time whilst
building a better economy for the future
which is why investment is so important
economic growth is so important
how is it mischaracterization of what
she told me twice
will you appreciate kay that i've been
working on the foreign affairs brief on
issues like the northern ireland
protocol
but you're telling me i didn't see the
interview okay
well there you go how do you know then
how do you know it's because
because i like the interview because i
know rachel and i know that she is
somebody who cares deeply about making
sure that people
are able to get by that we deal with
this you know this issue of inflation
that we're facing in our economy and i
think you've mischaracterized what she
said well if you didn't hear what the
the interview what was part of the
interview then there we are there were
two million views of it on uh my twitter
feed uh ed miliband uh trending on
twitter yesterday as well after calling
mishi sunak the dude from silicon valley
and the giant ponzi scheme when he was
talking uh lightning his likening his
career to a giant ponzi scheme um in
other words saying that this this
government is out of touch how would you
respond chancellor's doing a fantastic
job in very difficult circumstances he
helped the country get through the covet
crisis we've got the lowest unemployment
since 1974. he's working very hard to
attract investment and if we look at ed
miliband's record he was one of the
energy secretaries who failed to invest
in energy all those years ago which is
means that we are now playing catch up
in areas like nuclear energy and
renewable energy and these rishi sunak
is taking the right long-term
decisions for our country
you've called the northern ireland
protocol a very grave and serious
whereas the prime minister is saying
that all we need is minor tweaks
which one's correct
we need sensible pragmatic changes to
the northern ireland protocol to make it
work for the people of northern ireland
but the reality is it isn't working on
the ground
it has created political instability in
northern ireland we haven't seen the
executive form uh since february so we
do need to make these changes and these
changes will be make it better for
everyone they'll reduce the bureaucracy
on east-west trade they'll mean that the
people of northern ireland are able to
access the support like the vat cuts
we've brought in
in great britain and it will also mean
that people are able to get all of the
goods in northern ireland that are
available to the people of great britain
minor tweaks or grave concern which one
is it
well the situation in northern ireland
is of grave concern
the belfast good friday agreement was a
huge step change for northern ireland in
a positive direction we're now seeing
that undermined
by the fact that the northern ireland
protocol isn't working and that's why we
need to make changes to the northern
ireland protocol so the situation of
grave concern
is the situation
in the northern ireland political system
which we need to
fix through these changes to the
northern ireland protocol
now those tweaks minor or major
we're not changing everything in the
protocol through our legislation we are
protecting the north-south relationship
we're protecting the single electricity
market but there are some very serious
problems about east-west trade which we
need to fix we've proposed a solution
sharing commercial data having proper
enforcement so creating a green lane
into northern ireland that helps protect
the eu single market which is what
they're concerned of and also helps
protect
trade into northern ireland so we can
get a pragmatic solution i want the eu
to come to the negotiating table so we
can agree that together but if that
doesn't happen we do need to move ahead
delivering this
solution for the people of northern
ireland
okay okay um i think it's fair to say
foreign secretary and it's not of your
own making but um the government has
angered the dup the government has
angered the eu so where does that
actually leave us the uk are we sort of
somewhere a drift in the irish sea
we have put forward a solution
that base delivers uh for the people of
northern ireland that delivers for
uh
the problems that they've been facing
whether it's about tax or whether it's
about trade but also
delivers for the eu single market and
that's what we want to legislate for
it's not scrapping the protocol as some
people have claimed it's fixing the
protocol making it better make it work
better and that works for everybody
that's the solution we want to get to
um i just want to ask you a question on
behalf of louise who runs the brick here
she's the chief executive of uh
basically a lifeline for many people
here in wigan and she wants to know
what's going to happen
people are going back to work other
people can no longer come here to be a
volunteer what's the government going to
do to try to help organizations like
this with volunteers so that this
lifeline for so many people in wigan can
continue to be up and running
well first of all can i thank louise and
her team for the fantastic job they're
doing food banks offer a real uh support
for
for people and we do want to make sure
that they have enough
volunteers one of the uh one of the
issues we're facing of course is because
of the very high levels of employment uh
the fact that more people in work
sometimes it can be difficult uh to get
volunteer support but i would encourage
people to
help out with their uh local food bank
to get involved and i very much support
the work she's doing
okay uh just a thought before i let you
go uh foreign secretary you are a very
strong very successful politician and
woman as well of course how did you feel
yesterday when you heard that an np had
been arrested for rape
well i'm very very concerned about the
reports that i've heard clearly this is
a matter for the police
the police are currently working on the
case but
you know
it is worrying uh that we are seeing
these appalling these appalling uh
accusations
again
uh about a parliamentarian
do you feel that they should have been
um suspended or had the whip withdraw of
course we're innocent until proven
guilty but someone's been arrested for
rape is it right that they still have
the whip at this stage
i think it's a matter for the police
about whether that individual is named i
don't know who it is i know that
the police are looking at it and
investigating it and i think we need to
wait for the police to conduct those
investigations i understand that this
individual is not
on the parliamentary estate but i think
we need to allow the police to take
those investigations forward
understood but you are content for them
to keep the whip for now
well as i've said i don't know who they
are and i know the police are looking at
this case on an urgent basis
so you do feel it's content for them to
keep the whip for now
well i think it's a matter for the
police and it's a matter for law
enforcement and of course
there's a question about whether or not
the name is released at this well it's a
it's a question form no it's not a
police about whether it's kept or not
there is
it no but if if the whip
well if there was a disclosure about the
name of this individual there could be
an impact on the victim and that is a
matter for the police
okay good to talk to you foreign
secretary thank you for the time to join
us live from wigan this morning very
much appreciated thank you